in this video we're going to hopefully
understand why the complex form of a
comp or why the exponential form of a
complex number is actually useful so
let's say we wanted to find
so let's say we want to solve the
equation x to the third power is equal
to 1. so we want to find all of the real
and or complex roots of this equation
right over here this is the same thing
as x to the third minus 1 is equal to 0.
so we're looking for all of the real and
complex roots of this and there are ways
to do this without exponential form of a
complex number but what the the
technique we're going to see in this
video could be applied if this was x to
the 5th minus 1 or x to the 13th minus
1. and it's also going to show us kind
of the the patterns that emerge when you
start looking at things on an argand
diagram so to do this let's think about
let's think about the exponential
representation of one so let's just say
z is equal to one one is a complex
number it's a real number real not all
real numbers are also complex numbers
they're a subset they're part they're in
the complex plane they just don't have
an imaginary they just don't have an
imaginary part so let's draw this on an
argan diagram
so that's my real axis
this is my imaginary axis
and so this is the real this is the
imaginary
and if i wanted to represent z equals
one it only has a real part so let me
just draw one all around
negative one
negative one z
z looks like this
z would look like
z
would look like that a position vector
that just goes to one zero
one way to view it this is the same
thing is equal to one
plus
one plus zero i now let's put this in
exponential form
well its magnitude is pretty
straightforward the magnitude of z is
just the length of this vector or it's
the absolute value of 1. that's just
going to be that's just going to be 1.
now what's the argument
what's the argument of z what's the
angle that this vector makes with the
positive real axis what's on the
positive real axis it's a real number so
it has no angle so it's the arg of z is
zero so that might not be too
interesting so far we just wrote we just
figured out that one could be equal to
one is equal to
times e to the 0 i
0 i and this is kind of obvious e to the
0 this is going to be 0 0 times i 0 e to
the 0 is going to be 1 times 1 is equal
to 1. not a big deal there but what is
neat is that this argument you could
view it as 0 radians or you could go all
the way around and add 2 pi to it and
get to the same point you go all the way
around
and add 2 pi and get to the same point
so the argument of our complex number or
the number 1 really
could also be an angle of 2 pi or an
angle of 4 pi or an angle of 6 pi or an
angle of 8 pi so we can write 1 we can
write one is we can also write it as one
times e i won't write the one anymore
one times e to the two pi i
or
one times e
to the four
to the four pi i
and the reason why this is interesting
is in this equation
this equation right here can be written
in multiple ways it can be written as x
to the third
is equal to one
x to the third is equal to one it could
be written as
x to the third is equal to e to the 2 pi
i
e to the 2 pi i or it could be written
as x to the third is equal to e to the 4
pi i
e to the 4 pi i and this is interesting
and we're gonna see this in a second
let's take both sides of all these
equations to the one-third power to
solve for x
so to the one-third
we're going to take that to the
one-third we're gonna do that same thing
over here
we're just taking everything to the
one-third power to solve for the x's in
each of these equations
to the one third power so this first
equation over here becomes x is equal to
one
to the one third power which is just
equal to one now what's the second
equation become
this second equation x is equal to
e to the well this is going to be the 2
pi over 3 i power
e to the 2
pi
over 3
i power and then this equation over here
is going to be
so x is going to be equal to obviously
the 3 to the one third that just becomes
x to the one
x is going let me do that same blue
x over here is going to be equal to e to
the 4 pi
over
3 the 4 pi over 3
i so let's think about let's think about
this for a little bit what is this so we
could so immediately what's the argument
here so let me let me write let me these
are three different roots let me call
this x1 x2 and
x3 so these are three different numbers
one of the roots is one that's pretty
clear over here one is one of the cube
roots of itself but these are other
numbers and these are going to be
complex numbers so let's let's visualize
these numbers a little bit
so what is the argument
so for all of these so the magnitude of
x2
the magnitude of x2 is still clearly one
it's the coefficient out in front of the
e it's clearly one the magnitude of x3
let me do that same color the magnitude
of x3 is also clearly
going to be one but what is the argument
of x2
what is phi what is the argument what's
2 pi over 3
it's 2 pi over 3. so how would we draw
how would we draw x2
so the angle is 2 pi over 3 i always
it's easier for me to visualize in
degrees so 2 pi is 360 degrees 360
degrees divided by 3 is 120 degrees so
this is going to be 120 degrees is 60
short
of so it's going to look like this
it's going to look like this
just like this this is so this angle
right here its argument is going to be
120 degrees which is the same thing as 2
pi
as 2 pi over 3 and it's going to have
the exact same length let me do the same
color so this is x1 so that is this
green color
right over here
x2 is this magenta one right over here
and they all have the same magnitude so
we really just rotate we rotate 120
degrees and what about x3 what's its
argument
what's x3's argument
its argument is 4 pi
4 pi over 3 that's the same thing as
720 degrees
over
3 if we were to put into degrees and so
3 goes into 7 20 3 goes into 7 20. 3
goes into 720 was it 240
720 is it
240 right i should have known that so
240 degrees we're going to go 180
degrees and then go another 60 degrees
so it's going to be right over here it's
going to be right over here
so let me draw it like this it's going
to be right
over here so this is going to be
that angle right over there is 4 pi over
3 radians
4 pi over 3 radians which is equal to
which is equal to 240 degrees and once
again it has the same magnitude so we
just saw is when i take the cube roots
of this real number i'm essentially
taking the entire i guess we could call
it the entire circle or the entire 360
degrees or the entire two pi radians and
i'm dividing it into
into
angle into three essentially this is one
third then we have another 120 degrees
and then we have another 120 degrees and
so you kind of see the pattern of where
all of the roots are and in case you're
still not satisfied you're like well you
know you said you would find complex
roots yeah you know i i'm not used to
this or this is actually being complex
numbers i want to i actually want it to
be in the form a plus bi we can easily
figure it out from this right over here
so x2
x2 is going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to the cosine
the cosine of 2 pi
over 3
plus
i times the sine of 2 pi over 3.
sine of 2 pi
over 3. and if you look at this over
here we can figure out what those things
are going to be this is the angle right
over here
if this angle right here over here is 60
degrees which it is because this up here
is 30 degrees
and this the hypotenuse or the length is
one
then this over here square root of three
over two and that this distance right
over here is negative one half so x two
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to cosine of 2 pi
over 3
is negative
negative one half did i do that right
yep negative one half plus i times sine
of two pi over three that's this height
over here which is square root of three
over 2
i so that's x2 and we can do the exact
same thing with x3
x3 is going to be equal to its x value
why should its real value is going to be
the exact same thing it's going to be
negative one-half and then it's
y it's its imaginary value so this angle
right over here is also go this just
from the negative real axis down to the
vector is going to be negative 60
degrees so this height right over here
is going to be negative square root of
three over two so it's negative one half
minus the square root of three over two
i so using this technique we were able
to find the three
roots the three complex roots of one
this is one of them
this is another one
and of course one is one of them as well
where did we do that one is one of them
as well you could use this exact same
technique if we were finding the fourth
roots we would take the 300 the 2 pi
radians or the 360 degrees and divide it
into four and so it would actually be
this it would be i it would be negative
one it would be negative i and we know
if you take i to the fourth you get one
if you take negative i to the fourth you
get one and if you take negative one to
the fourth you get one and if you take
one to the fourth you get one and so you
could do this you could find the eighth
roots of one using this technique
now the other question that might be
popping in your brain is why did i stop
at e to the 4 pi i why didn't i go on
why didn't i go on and say well this is
equal to e to the 6 pi i and look for
another root and so if i did that
if i did that if i said x to the third
let's say i wanted to find a fourth root
here maybe x to the third is equal to e
to the 6
pi i and i take both sides of this
equation to the 1 3 power so i'd get x
is equal to taking this to the one third
i get e to the 2 pi
i'll get e to the 2 pi i well what's e
to the 2 pi i e to the 2 pi i will just
get us back to 1. so when i added 2 pi
again it just gets us back to this root
again and if i added if i took e to the
6 pi if i took e to the 8 pi i would get
this root again so you're going to get
only three roots if you're taking if
you're taking if you're taking well if
you're finding if you're finding the
third roots of something anything beyond
that it just becomes redundant